друзі це треба припиняти цю дурню це
дурня це рахункова палата України це
палата Яка має
рахувати наші гроші ваші гроші ті хто
зараз нас дивляться а ще гроші отих
людей оцим прапорцем Європейського союзу
з прапором Сполучених Штатів Америки
вони хочуть знати як порахують гроші а в
нас будь ласочка в нас є людина вона
відпрацювала своє в антимонопольному
тепер вам порахує гроші все нормально
так не має бути це ніхто в світі не
зрозуміє Я розумію що Президент говорить
на прес-конференції є в мене
чотири-5'ять менеджерів то ми тепер
розуміємо це чотири-5'ять сусідів чи
чотири-5'ять друзів і вони будуть по
шахматки ходить сьогодні один завтра
інший може вони в лотерею де переходять
з посади на посаду друзі це треба
припиняти